[Music]
hi I'm Chet Haase I'm Dan Sandler and
I'm will McGee and welcome to what's new
in Android or maybe we should call it
what's Q in Android
they chuckled you said they wouldn't you
said it was a dumb joke it is a dumb
joke but they chuckled anyway maybe
we'll call it what's new and Q which
begs the question Q it does beg that
exact question I don't know we're gonna
have to see so where's this gonna end up
everybody wonders what it stands for I'm
sorry what was the question
it's gonna be like this for 40 minutes
buckle up let's talk about system UI as
you know my favorite topic and I want to
start with a serious topic I need to
tell you about the danger of saws system
alert window I hope that was clear
system alert window is what we're
talking about here we call them a saws
they're dangerous but you as experienced
developers already know this right apps
showing a system alert window they're
always running which impacts RAM battery
performance and so forth and there are
also some really serious security and
privacy considerations to having a
transparent overlay from a third-party
app on your screen this is one of those
features that we created in a simpler
time when we were like oh wow what can
people do with this now we know let me
add you another reason that you should
stay away from system alert windows
Android go devices will no longer grant
this permission at all
so you just won't be able to draw an
overlay if you're depending upon that
for a key part of your apps UI you're
gonna need to find another solution in
fact if you have a you know sort of
circular chat person representation kind
of thing in your app you might really be
in a tough spot but relax we've got you
this is what my team does system UI we
see a UI paradigm taking hold in the
wild we take it we learn about it we
make it safer more reusable and then we
contribute it back to the framework for
everybody's to use on Android so in API
29 we have a Developer Preview of
something that we call bubbles
bubbles is an implementation for any app
that wants to use it of a floating chat
bubble that you can use to connect to
your app and effectively you tie it to a
notification you add in some bubble
metadata here including an icon and an
intent to launch an activity will
actually put your activity inside a
floating window will put your activity
inside a floating window when the user
touches that bubble so there's something
we've been working on for a while but we
really need feedback we're excited for
you to use it let us know how it works
the way this is going to work is in
queue you can go turn this on in
developer settings and start
implementing support for it in your app
or as a user you can start seeing which
apps or have moved over to this new
system in the future we'll move that
opt-in up to a full user setting so that
users can turn on bubble support and
then eventually the saws will be fully
deprecated and all apps using that
paradigm to do bubbles will move over to
the bubbles API there is a talk about
this Thursday 9:30 right after breakfast
what's new in the Android u OS user
interface see they're here Stage one one
of those it'll be on YouTube too alright
now that we're done talking about that I
want to bring lights down a little bit
and talk about dark theme
from the Google finally Department is
finally an end-user feature in core
Android it's no longer tied to time of
day by the way so this whole mode auto
time thing that's done forget it it is
just user once it on user wants it off
that's how dark-themed works so if you
want to dark-themed your app you have a
few options option a and this is the
easiest is just to use the Android
themes that we already have that support
this so app compat day-night that's been
there for a while we now have a device
default day/night if you're trying to
match the devices style you're making
like more of a utility kind of app and
then you can actually pull out just
elements of the day/night current theme
like colors and things like that to you
know just pull in accent colors now your
other option is this is actually kind of
wild we have this thing in queue called
force dark that you can turn on this is
this is kind of some eccentric wizardry
that the graphics team has put together
if you want the OS will just invert your
app for you just like flip it into dark
mode you don't have to do anything else
except that it's actually kind of
terrifying when some things like photos
are inverted so you can actually opt-out
individual views from being put into
force dark if you're using that in your
app at all so you should try that it may
actually save you quite a bit of l2
development time option C you've always
been able to do this just sort of do it
yourself look at the UI mode change all
of the themes in your app switch it
around that's that's always fine as long
as you're looking at the current
configuration to know whether it you
should be doing dark theme or light
theme and then of course option D which
I do not recommend is just ignore it and
then you'll be the only app with a
searingly white UI in between other
neatly dark themed apps in the users
device I don't do that we have another
talk about that that is Thursday at also
it how did we end up with both system UI
talks at the same time on different
anyway we're really into concurrency and
we
you know if we just use co-routines
Thursday at 9:30 there's a separate talk
about dark steam and gestures in android
q which I encourage you to attend next
up in system UI let's talk about sharing
and as we all know sharing is caring and
in this particular context what that
means is we my team Android we care
about performance custom share targets
coming from your app content previews
copy to clipboard
did I mention performance these are
things that we really care about but the
share sheet in P kind of needs a little
more of that caring a little more TLC so
let me present to you the share sheet in
queue
it's awesome so we've got okay this bad
boy can fit so many icons look we've got
content preview that does images and
text depending on what you put into the
clip data we have a new sharing shortcut
API that does not synchronously and
serially launch every app and ask it hey
what you got it's lightning fast
we've got copy to clipboard this just
this is the button it's like right there
at the top why did we not think of this
before
and it is really really fast beautiful
animations I'm so excited for you to try
it it's in beta 3 check it out and we're
talking about that guess what on
Thursday at 9:30 now let's talk
interruptions
about interruptions Thank You Chet yeah
interruptions notifications that ask for
your attention
urgently we did a little back of the
envelope math most of our users get at
least one of these interrupts something
beeping popping up whatever at least one
per waking hour but a substantial
fraction like every 10 minutes or more
frequently and our user research says
that this is too much people feel like
they're getting too many interruptions a
great deal of that is due to people's
lives being full of interruptions but
aren't your device your phone should
help you manage that people want to be
interrupted but only for what matters we
want notifications to just you know
click chill out you know what's it
what's a good word
home quiet would eat on grade do gentle
gentle is the word I think he was
killing that French no that was bad
so we're gonna take those notifications
that aren't trying to get your attention
and we're gonna put them down here in a
separate section we'll call this the
gentle section that leaves the urgent
stuff the things that can't wait are the
things that make noise to get your
attention those go at the top and we
call those priority so the question of
course is developers is what takes
priority because if everything is
priority nothing is first of all apps
can still say hey this is an important
thing right and that causes a pop up a
heads-up notification we call it
internally you know this so you use that
sparingly to not annoy the user
we've also always applied and we're
continuing to tune our os-level
heuristics for how to adjust these
things to try to figure out what is the
right actual presentation for this
notification in the moment so we'll
actually make sure that thing is like
basic device functions like hey you're
out about to run out of battery or
here's an incoming phone call those
things are a priority we're also going
to continue to prioritize communication
from people which we've done for a few
releases now and also events alarms
things that you really don't want to
miss and then as always you should know
this by now my team feels very strongly
the user always gets the final say so
you'll be able to long press on a
notification and very easily switch it
from priority to gentle and back to
decide which bucket it fits in in in
beta 3 we're trying something a little
exciting where we don't actually show
the icons for those gentle notifications
in the status bar let us know how you
feel about that we're still trying to
decide how we want to make that work in
future versions of the beta software
while we're talking about notifications
I think this was mentioned in at least
one of the other two keynotes today we
talked about a recall of notification
actions but these smart replies actually
or something that the OS is now
supplying to all messaging style
notifications we're just gonna throw
them in there and you've seen this in
you know Google Apps up until now now
every app on the device is gonna have
the ability to have this in messaging
style you can even opt into it for other
notification types as well if you want
and this is automatically generated
based on the content of
notification so that's the last bit of
notifications news and we're talking
about it guess one there is day at 9:30
that's right
all right last thing and then
contractually I'm required to give up
the clicker I want to talk to you about
gesture navigation so this is something
as you know we've been working on for a
little while we started hacking away at
it in P sort of in baby steps but it's
important to talk about just briefly
like why is this even important why are
we going to gesture navigation overall
in the operating system the basic idea
is to just get less system UI in the way
of your beautiful content that's not
really we do we do more beautiful what
would be the most beautiful thing that
we could put here right right okay so in
the case of gesture navigation on at the
OS level we noticed the UI paradigm in
the wild and we took a look at it
understood it made it safer more
reusable and added it so the framework
does this sound familiar to you this is
what we do at Android and in this case
it was actually devices that we're
pioneering more immersive experiences
but all with different gestures where
you would slide and poke the screen in
order to get it to do different things
so we actually worked with OEMs on this
and that's one careful's to do a gentle
gentle is the word of the day remember
we actually worked with OEMs on this and
came up with a standard that is much
simpler and we can start to see across
the ecosystem so as app developers you
need to prepare yourselves one of the
things you want to do is simply draw
edge to edge I mean the whole point of
this is to give you more more chet face
so go ahead and actually draw underneath
the status bar underneath the navigation
bar where you might not ordinarily have
done but you want to avoid putting
clickable things there because those
clicks are potentially gonna get
captured by for example this status bar
you also want to figure out where the
gesture areas are and we're
standardizing what these gestures are
but you'll actually want to look at the
insects to figure out where there are
regions where a swipe from the edge is
actually going to be taken over by the
operating system
obviously we've had that for a long time
from the top of the screen and the
bottom and now it's happening from the
left and right so you don't want to put
draggable things there but of course
clicks will still work touches taps if
you have a situation in your app where
you really really really need to be able
to drag in from the side so you've got a
game or you've got a side bar navigation
pattern or you've got a drawing app I
hear those are popular you can actually
use things called exclusion rectangles
to allocate a part of the screen to say
hey I actually need side gestures in
this particular area so if you've got a
horizontally scrolling thing or again
that door you could take away just you
know one of those system gesture areas
and bring it to your app but remember if
the user is going to be relying on this
to go back that it needs to really
really make sense that it's not gonna do
that in your app and we are talking
about this once again on Thursday at
9:30 in a talk about dark-themed and
gestures with that hand it back to check
thanks we're gonna do a really quick
drive-by in some of the random platform
improvements that we've had recently
webview had a recent change to introduce
try chrome which is separating webview
from chrome they used to be a lockstep
so you update one you update the other
now they are more separate makes it a
little bit easier to deal with that as a
user
we also detect when the render is hung
so it's easy to set a callback that
callback and do something about it if
you need to accessibility a couple of
important changes it's way easier to set
accessibility actions now that's a
one-liner and also sometimes your UI the
amount of time it needs to stay on the
screen depends on situations that are
related to the user you can actually
query from the accessibility manager how
long that transit in UI should stick
around there's a talk on accessibility
Wednesday at 9:30 go to that for more we
also make changing into text so in API
that's at 23 we introduce hyphenation
and it looked beautiful so we turned it
on by default however we then measure
the performance of that thing and it
turns out it's 2 to 2.5 times slower
than that's using hyphenation it also
turns out that most layouts are slow
because of text measurements so in cue
it's now off by default again
so sorry about that - it we have jet
pack libraries to help you with this but
you know re-enable it if you really need
hyphenation
we also made it easier to find system
phones until now you had to parse an XML
file that was somewhere in the system
don't do that anymore use this new API
we also have an API for this for native
applications so it should write a game
or anything with native code because you
can use this new C API to find all the
fonts also a bunch of new features that
I barely understand but I'm sure they
are amazing so we finally have
implementations for line background span
and line a height span those we have two
interfaces that we shipped in the SDK
with that implementation sounds like a
pretty stupid thing to do so we fixed it
text appearance pan used to not read all
the attributes that were available in
text appearance we also fix that we have
new API is line breaker and measure text
to let you know break lines the way you
want and we have segment support photon
encoding so this is useful for users in
Myanmar if you want to know more about
text tomorrow at 6:30 there's a sorry
chat a talk called best practices for
using text in Android and really it
slightly related to text so in queue
introduce this to magnifier API that we
use when we're doing the text selection
and you can use it to magnify pretty
much anything you want we added new
capabilities in that API in queue so now
you can change the corner radius of the
window you can change the position you
can change the zoom of the magnification
and you can change the elevation to
control the shadow so private API is
this is a project that we started in the
P release where we started limiting
access to private API we really don't
want application developers calling
these things because they can't change
between releases in a lot of cases
there's no good reason to be calling
that private API maybe we introduced a
public method in the time since you
first introduced that code into your
application maybe you just missed it in
the docs whatever the reason is often
there's actually a much better public
way to do the thing you're trying to do
so we're enhancing the documentation to
point you to the right thing or in cases
where there isn't a public method and
there's no particularly good reason why
there shouldn't be we're introducing a
new public method or if there can't be
simply a new method for maybe there's a
approach to do this so we're also
documenting that instead and then where
we do we're restricting these things by
putting them on a grey list which says
yep it'll still work through this
release but as a future releases this
will no longer work so it's time for you
to migrate your code this is all about
fixing crashes on for the user where
it's going to crash for them because we
end up changing an internal method
without realizing that you're using it
in a completely unexpected way and we've
seen applications that use reflection to
access fields that have had getters and
setters since API level 1 so if you're
doing that this can tell me why I really
really don't get it there's good
documentation on all the changes that
we've made there and what we're doing
about this so go to the
developer.android.com site for more
information there's some great changes
in arch a couple of things we want to
talk about app profiles in the cloud so
this gives a better start up for a
recently installed application here's
how it works nice diagram I stole from
their slides basically all these users
in the world using this application
we're doing compiles doing the ahead of
time compiles we get the code we figure
out what needs to be compiled on the
device we create that device code we
upload all of these into the cloud and
we figure out ok what's the base set of
stuff that needs to be pre compiled for
the apps but launched faster and now
when you install that application you
also install pre compiled code for your
device so you don't have to go through
the compilation step yourself because
other people did it across the world for
you the team has also worked a lot on
startup improvements in general in
addition to that other stuff and also
worked on a generational garbage
collector after art came out they they
had a generational collector but that
was turned off I believe in the oh
really we give a talk on that yes we did
and I'm sure we said oh and it was
because they came out with a new
concurrent collector and that didn't
work out to introduce that at that time
so now we have a GC generational
collector again it collects new objects
first so it turns out that a lot of the
garbage being created are things that
are really transient objects so we can
look through that list first it's much
smaller much quicker we can get all the
space that you need back
in most cases without doing a full GC
cheaper faster better and that's what
we're all about there's a GC or art talk
Wednesday at 11:30 you should go to for
more information ever heard of that
how many of you are using kathleen
alright
so in the words of Chet in the keynote
this morning we are increasingly cutting
first whatever that means
so what this means that all the new API
is that were introduced in cue come with
no ability no ability annotation so
that's very useful for curtains also
useful to use the java programming
language and speaking of the annotations
now we enforced null ability as an error
and not as a warning anymore when your
target cue so we will help you build
better applications someone is really
happy about this over there all right
cut in one point three point thirty also
brought incremental annotation
processing in kpt so all right I'll just
start using annotation processors and so
there's a talk tomorrow at 12:30 what's
to incur clean on Android and we've also
adding support for covert scenes in
various jetpack libraries like room and
there is a talk on Thursday
understanding Kirkland co-routines on
Android and if you attend the jetpack
sessions on app architecture components
you will hear more about this security
this is where I'm out of my depth so
bear with me
CLS 1.3 is now enabled by default and
thanks to the one RTT connections are
40% faster I think that was right we
many improvements to the biometric
dialogue so you can request implicit
confirmation instead of explicit
confirmation and if there's an issue
with the biometric recognition you can
also use a passcode fallback so the user
can just enter a passcode and finally we
have a jetpack security library that I
know almost nothing about so please go
out and this talk security on Android
what's next on Thursday
finally in power manager we introduced a
new API you can register a listener to
be notified when the device goes on
their thermal throttling so if you're
doing too much work or if the device is
getting hot for whatever reason you can
use that listener to backup do less work
or adapt what your application is doing
for instance a game you can change the
quality of the graphics to avoid the
device running too hot and you know
be turning off or using too much battery
and an API has had some improvements now
60 new ops to take advantage of as well
as massive latency reduction and there
is a talk today at 6 p.m. so go to that
for more ml n n API goodness and the
extent that you know about mission
earning yes sure
preference is okay so you may already
know this this is not news but if you're
using Android preference you shouldn't
that is now deprecated we want to move
everybody away from the platform onto
the jetpack version of that which is
Android X dot preference we have some
sample code here so you simply load in
this XML code will show an example of
that it's got some XML here that
populates this UI so you have these
categories easy to set up
we've got built-in widgets for you
checkboxes and switches all looks good
it's all pretty easy to set up so you
should use that and if you want to know
more about that there was a quick talk
at ATS in the fall which is on YouTube
so go check out that talk architecture
components lots of things going on there
all the time work manager just went
stable 101 and 201 and they continue to
work on more capabilities there same
thing with navigation controller just
went stable recently there's a talk on
both of these well there's a talk at i/o
there's also an older ADF talk on work
manager savestate for view model just
went alpha this week easier handling of
process restarts benchmarking new
jetpack API for handling performance
testing in your codes and there's a talk
on that Thursday 1:30 and finally life
cycles live data and room now deep
co-routine integration as well as more
capabilities there that will be covered
in what's new and architecture
commonness talk tomorrow at 10:30 cam
racks library we touched on this briefly
in the technical keynote earlier easy to
use camera library it works around the
issues that you have of having device
specific implementations some of the
platform api's puts that workaround
directly in the library itself so it's
much easier for you to use
it's backwards compatibility compatible
all the way to Android lollipop and it's
much more concise API so your code
should be much smaller to do all the
right things that you need to do and
there's an extension to add on we're
working with manufacturers on this to
provide access to device specific
functionality like HDR and you'll soon
see some of those extensions coming out
for those manufacturers not just their
new devices but also existing devices so
we have a lot of levers in jet pack to
make your life easier but there's one
areas where we not we have not done
enough building Android device remains
pretty difficult you know and we
designed our UI took it a long time ago
over 10 years ago in the state of the
art has evolved a little bit since then
so we took inspiration from what you've
told us from things that Greg dodge svgs
leaves oh and yeah our even our own
flutter and we decided we'll then to
invest sorry in the declarative approach
to reactive programming so like Chad
mentioned earlier in the keynote we're
working on the new toolkit called
jetpack compose it's on next-generation
UI toolkit its unbundled so you'll be
able to put it inside your application
will be able to deliver updates whenever
we want it is reactive and it's also
entirely written in Catalan we rely on
the Curtin compiler plug-in to make this
work to make this work it's to make it
as efficient as possible we try to avoid
doing as much as possible at runtime and
what we're doing today is will not
deliver a new binaries you can use in
production but we're open sourcing all
the code we're putting everything in USB
and as of today the entire team will
start working in the SPD directly so you
can join us you can look at the source
code you can play with it you can give
us feedback and you can even contribute
if you want so I want to show you a demo
so can we please switch to the demo
machine can we just go awkwardly stand
behind him how he does it yes so I
that's bizarre
so I do work a lot with Chet and it does
make a lot of good jokes he also makes a
lot of bad ones so I built myself a
small app to be able to count those bad
jokes and I'm going to show you how to
build an app so this is an ad that's
using jetpack compos one of the things
that we want to do is we want to make it
a lot easier to create new widgets or
new component
and we jetpack compose a component it's
just a single function so you have an
annotation here but we're not using an
annotation processor we're using a
cutting compiler plugin so all you have
to do is you create this function every
parameter of the function is effectively
a parameter or property of your
component here I'm gonna add some state
so I'm not going to go into the details
but I'm just creating a counter it's
initialized to 0 it's back to its the
intro state of my component then I'm
gonna create a column which is the
account of a vertical linearlayout I'm
gonna put a button in it and you can see
that the button I just reused the title
parameter I received and in the unclick
property I can just increase the value
of my counter then I want to display the
value of that counter and so I use a
label I'm just going to use again my
state bad jokes sorry and that's it now
let's run this oh I forgot one thing I
need to instantiate my component
here we go all right let's cancel this
let's run we are also working hard on
making a compilation step as fast as
possible this is still heavily under
development so don't worry you will get
better but here you have an entire app
that's really reactive as you can see I
did not have to write an XML so there is
no XML layout there is no annotation
processor there's no data binding
there's no listeners and when the a
panel shows up I'm gonna blame Gradle
it also what always works it's very
unfair but he always works alright this
is a bill from last week so please cross
your fingers from for me it should work
it's worked until now
it's worked backstage just before the
talk you know we weren't standing behind
you last night
I'll try again thank you for your
support
[Applause]
like I said it's not ready for
production yet those are the early days
so if someone could please fix this for
us the source code is available oh here
we are
yay all right and when I click look at
that it increases the label no listeners
all right thanks I think that demo
really clicked can we get back to the
slides please
all right so if you want to know more
you can check out this website did
Android cons jetpack compose you will
find all the information on how to get
to the source code we have written me so
you can use the special version of
Android students required to make this
work and there is a talk tomorrow at
3:30 we're going to go into more details
about why we're doing this and how these
things works but the UI toolkit is not
just about the new stuff that we're
working on that will be available
sometime in the future we're also still
supporting and enhancing all the stuff
that you're using right now a good
example of that is viewpager - we've
been asked for fixes as well as more
functionality in viewpager for many
years we were sort of painted into a
corner with what we had well we really
wanted was a view pager that was built
around a much more flexible model so we
built this around recyclerview so
recyclerview capabilities but view pager
api is it should be very familiar and
easy to port - we support RTL something
that was missing for years we also
support vertical paging who knew people
actually want to scroll the other way
who knew and much more a much better
support for notifications from data set
changes as well so please check that out
alpha for very recently so development
ongoing but hopefully usable in the
meantime and continued investment in our
existing UI toolkit we're gonna
introduce soon something called view
bindings basically we want you to not
have to call find you buy ID anymore
we also don't want you to use annotation
postures with this because they tend to
slow down your your build so instead we
generate binding code from the XML outs
layouts directly it is now safe and it
is type safe and I'm going
you an example so there is a talk
tomorrow and architecture component
where you eat is going to talk about
this in a little more details but he has
an example we have a file called search
item that XML from that file at compile
time using the similar technology that
we use for data binding we generate a
class called search item bindings and
that search item bindings contains a
bunch of fields or properties that you
can use to access the views directly so
for instance the route view of this
layout is in a property called route
view so you can just say binding that
route view and that's it you have access
to that top-level view and as you can
see this also a text view called package
name and we again we have a property
called package name and it has the type
text view so you can call dot text on it
directly and this thing is really smart
it looks at all the configuration for
that XML file and finds the type that
works across all the configurations
now graphics and media we're going to go
through this a little bit quickly so we
had this class called porter def that
mode on Android that was not documented
for the longest time it's very confusing
because it contains modes that have
nothing to do with poplar and death so
in queue we're introducing a new class
called blend mode that basically
replaces photo def that mode what other
that mode still works but we are also
adding missing modes like hard light and
soft light so basically now we have all
the modes that you can find in sketch or
Adobe Photoshop and applications like
this so that should make your designer
is happy
we're also exposing an API called render
node this is what we use for hardware
acceleration inside the UI toolkit so
yeah it's just by the views internally
and it contains the display so it's all
the join comments that you issue on a
canvas one in your on draw function it
also contains this page properties such
as rotation alpha scale and things like
this and a render node can contain other
render nodes so you can build a tree of
render nodes for super efficient
rendering so here's I use them you just
create a new instance you give you the
position and the size then by calling
begin recording you get a special canvas
that you can use to record comments on
the the render node itself and when you
don't done you called end recording then
you can manipulate the properties so if
you want to fade the content of that
Trainer node you don't have to re-record
all your join commands you can just
change the Alpha property and again that
is exactly what views do for me when
you're done with it inside
you're on draw method you have to check
that the canvas you're gonna render onto
is hot works already and if it is you
can call the raw render node and pass
the render node you just created you can
use render node to create shadows
without using a view a render node can
have an outline so now you don't need to
create a brand-new view which is a very
heavy object just to create a shadow
inside your custom view for instance
we're also exposing something called a
Hardware renderer which is what we use
to render the render nodes so again used
by the tool kit is only in renders all
those nodes onto a surface the cool
thing about how do i render is that it
lets you control control the light
source that you that we use in metal
design so we measured then we cast
dynamic shadows on all the objects with
the position of the light source has
been fixed by the designers with
hardware render you can move that light
source around for pretty interesting
effects so here's how it works
you create a hollow renderer you give it
a surface then you set the content root
of the renderer as a render node and
then you just request for a frame to be
issued here are the methods you can use
to control the light source we can
change the alpha of the ambient shadows
and the directions and you can also
change the position and the size of the
light source so here's a quick demo that
shows you what you can do okay let's try
this again
okay the shadow should be moving around
and changing ah here we go
I have no luck with demos today as you
can see we're not moving the object and
the shadow is only moving and changing
blur because the light source itself is
moving around how do i bitmaps that is
not a new API but now a hollow a bitmap
can write a rap a hardware buffer in a
hollow a buffer is something that can be
jarred by OpenGL by the camera or
various other hardware units they are
useful because that lets you use a
something that changes frequently as a
bitmap without incurring the cost of a
texture upload which is something that
happens every time you modify a regular
bitmap and basically you can use it to
wrap surfaces so here I have an example
it's a very silly example but it's a lot
lotty animation that's using Hardware
rendering to render into a surface then
it's wrapped into a bitmap that said as
a bitmap shader on the paint that's used
to draw the text it could be a video it
could be OpenGL rendering so
do a lot of really cool things in your
application and I'm going to keep the
code itself basically we use an image
reader you have to create a new instance
an image reader will give you a surface
that you can use to render onto either
by locking the the canvas or giving it
to the hardware renderer and every time
an image is available you can acquire a
hardware buffer and then you can call
bitmap that wrap hardware buffer to get
an actual bitmap and then finally we can
use that bitmap inside the bitmap shader
so in summary this is all the classes
you need to make this work it's very
simple and self-explanatory I'm gonna
move on I think those are all the
graphics classes we have in the platform
pretty much surface control is a way to
talk to surface flinger directly again
we're running out of time so I'm going
to skip that there's new NDK api's but
they are super cool well can all devices
all new devices they're all new 64-bit
devices that will ship from now on will
be required to ship with Vulcan 1.1 so
if you have questions about Vulcan
please come to the graphics office hours
tomorrow afternoon angle this is
something experimental we have OpenGL ES
running on top of Vulcan this will allow
us to deliver updates to the OpenGL ES
driver effectively as just a simple apk
right now it's nothing inside the
developer options and inside your apk
you also have to opt in if you want to
know more about this feature again
please come to the office hours in
Android all we introduced a white color
game which were rendering we are using
16-bit color depth unfortunately it was
using a lot of memory it was also using
a lot of battery so now we use 8-bit
color depth and it solves this issues
again oh and we have a bunch of API so
color long is just like you know all
those color ins that you're used to
those are no more powerful because the
red should choose the college space and
now we have a bunch of new ideas on
canvas so before you could render what
game with bitmaps now you can draw
anything with canvas in the web game
modes so again if you have questions
office hours please audio playback then
you can capture all the audio on the
device there's a new class for that you
have to opt in or out if your app
doesn't target Android cue you
automatically up to the out if your app
does target Q you will be opted in by
default so in case you're playing
something that should not be recorded
make sure to check out those api's and
turn it off really quick run-through
there are a lot of very important
privacy changes the most developer
probably need to understand we're not
gonna have a lot of time to cover them
in depth so it's very fortunate that we
have at least three privacy talks at i/o
that you should check out there's also
really good documentation on the
developer site for the preview external
storage this is about making sure that
apps can't by default access files
created by all these other apps target
SDK P this is to help migration there is
no change from previous behavior but if
you're targeting Q then you our sandbox
died default you only have access to
your own files you can get access to
media files by using the traditional
storage permission as well as the media
store API s if you want access to photo
metadata you need to use the storage
permission plus a location permission
and if you still need access to all
files maybe you are actually a file
browser there is a manifest flag that
you can look into for more information
and please go to the talk Wednesday at
1:30 for more information on that
changes to location we now have a
tri-state for a location the locate the
user needs to give you permission to get
access to location if you're running in
the backgrounds an app can say I want
location at all time and the user can
say no you'll only get it when you're in
the foreground so we leave that up to
the user and there is a new permission
you're after request for background
access talking on that tomorrow morning
so please go to that we are restricting
applications from launching activities
when they're in the background so in
order to actually start an activity if
you are used to doing it doing this you
need to either be in the foreground to
begin with or you need to get pending
intent from a foreground app or from the
system or a broadcast from the system or
the best practice is to launch a
foreground notification then that is in
the foreground and it can launch the
activity basically the user needs to be
involved they need to understand what's
actually going on talk on this tomorrow
morning early so go to that camera if
you're used to getting camera
characteristics we restrict access to
device specific data so if you're
getting these kinds of pieces of
information you now need camera
permission to
get those and there's more information
again tomorrow at 8:30 connectivity
really whipping through this really
quickly you cannot disable and enable
Wi-Fi on the fly from your application
anymore instead the approved practice is
to use a settings panel if you really
need the user to toggle this for some
specific capability there's a new
settings capability that we give you
where you can pop up a Settings panel
directly inline in your app for specific
capabilities of internet Wi-Fi NFC and
volume and it works like this basically
asked for that thing and it pops up the
panel as your application is running in
the foreground works like a charm and
with that I think Dan wants to say oh I
thought wow thank you thank you all so
much for joining us here
[Applause]
[Music]